[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
la nuit veut un citron en uruguay
être le problème
je
comme la cuisine de l'écurie
ne reçoit pas doit provenir de bagazán
[Musique]
spectacle de gilo a voté pour obama
fils de voyou
[Musique]
ici
à voir en direct pacte à tenir
la nourriture fait mal
avoir
non
ses rivaux et la foule seremia ne pouvaient pas
et personnel
tu es quelqu'un de son auteur serrons la main
ou
[Musique]
habitent
le corps en dessous
[Musique]
toi
actualités 17
dans lequel je ne te dois rien
ça lui est arrivé ils sont si tendres
et crois-moi est cru
bombes d'un million de soles
ce jour des vivants
tu es mon bateau
m
ou non
[Musique]
bien
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]